(deep tones resonating)
(tape fast forwarding)
- Okay, everybody, greetings.
Welcome. Happy Tuesday.
Our job today is to get
through the Habsburgs.
I wanna start with making a
few remarks about mistakes,
my own and those of others.
Okay, so the funny thing
about giving a class
where there were two million views online
is that I can hear from
a large number of people
about things that go on in this class.
So I just wanna say to those
of you who are watching online,
you are right.
Milorad Pavic, the author of
"Dictionary of the Khazars"
was a Serb and not a Croat.
I'm very sorry.
And on etymology of punch, obviously,
I should have said that's
a common Indo-European root
that is shared in the
Slavic and other languages.
Okay, as far as errors
in the transcription,
please do not email me about
errors in the transcription.
Email the people who are
doing the transcription,
and that email address
is right over there,
and the cameraman is going to give you
that email address there.
So if you find errors in the
transcription, do not email me.
Thank you very much.
(class chuckling)
(chuckling) Okay, so we
have a really important
and interesting job today,
which is to get through
the Habsburg family.
So families matter a lot in history.
Larger forces matter too.
Structural forces matter too.
Climate matters, geology
matters, economics matter,
but individuals and families
matter very much as well.
This would be a very
different war if someone
besides Volodymyr Zelenskyy
were president of Ukraine.
This would be a very
different war if someone
besides Joe Biden were
president in the United States.
Individuals do matter, families do matter,
and it's important to have
them inside history as well.
It's an especially easy case
to make for the Habsburgs
because they were in power
in some form or other
for about 600 years, one place or another,
and for sometimes they were in
power over much of the world.
So the historian A. J. P. Taylor wrote
that for about half a millennium,
it wasn't that the Habsburgs turned
around the history of Europe,
it was that the history of
Europe turned around them,
and for about a hundred years,
you could even say as much
about the history of the world.
So if you are going to be a history major
or if you're going to be someone
especially who's focusing
on the history of Europe,
and there's one family
name that you should know,
this is probably the family
name that you should know.
So we are going to get around
to why the Habsburgs are so important
to the history of Ukraine,
but we're gonna make sure first,
and this is gonna be
the bulk of the lecture,
that we have a sense of
who the Habsburgs are.
So if the Habsburgs were so important,
why is it that no one
talks that much about them,
or, more interestingly, why is it that
of all the peoples around the world,
the people who remember
the Habsburgs fondly
tend to be in Western Ukraine?
So the Habsburg touched,
the Habsburgs touch all kinds of people,
including the Aztecs, including the Inca,
they touched all kinds of people,
but they're remembered
fondly in Western Ukraine.
By the end of the lecture,
you should have a sense
of why it is that
they're remembered fondly
in Western Ukraine.
In terms of the overall
arguments and method
that we've been using in this class,
this is gonna be one more
example of how friction
or contact between larger
powers, between empires,
has to do with the creation of the nation.
The Habsburgs are going to
turn out to be very important
in the origins of Ukraine,
and yet, and yet, and yet,
when the Habsburgs, when
Maria Theresia takes part
in the First Partition of Poland in 1772
and brings in a tiny bit of territory
where most people speak Ukrainian,
she is thinking many things,
but she is certainly not
thinking about Ukraine
or the history of Ukraine,
or the future of Ukraine.
Nevertheless, this little encounter,
one tiny part of where
Ukrainian is spoken in the world
and also one tiny part
of the Habsburg monarchy,
that overlap between one tiny part
of the zone where Ukrainian is spoken
and one tiny part of the Habsburg world,
that little tiny overlap,
which is called Galicia,
is going to turn out to
be very, very important
for the history of the Ukrainian nation.
It's gonna be important
for a certain kind of,
a especially certain kind of moment.
I'm gonna say the 1880s to the
1980s, for about a century,
Galicia is going to be
the most important part
of what's now Ukraine.
That period comes and that period goes.
It's already gone, so with all due respect
to those of you who are from Halychyna,
that period is now passed.
The center, the natural center,
of European politics, sorry,
of Ukrainian politics
is actually the East.
It's the East now, and it's
the East for most of the time
that we're teaching in this class,
but for a century or so,
Galicia is extremely important,
and you might even argue necessary, right?
So you can imagine there
might be an essay question,
which would be something like,
if Galicia had not been part
of the Habsburg monarchy,
what would've happened to Ukraine, right?
That's how important this zone is.
So we're talking about a moment.
We're talking about a moment
when some Ukrainian-speaking
territory is part
of the Habsburg monarchy.
That moment lasts from 1772 to 1918.
And then we're talking about
a moment where that zone,
we will be later talking about a moment
where that zone is crucial
to Ukraine as a whole,
which is roughly the 1880s to the 1890s.
Okay, so, but my goal here
is to make sure you know
who the Habsburgs are
because if you walked away
from this class saying the Habsburgs,
I mean, with all due respect
to the history of Ukraine,
if you walked away from
this class thinking
the Habsburgs are important
because of this thing they did
in Galicia for a few decades,
that would be an unfortunately
nationalistic interpretation
of this family, so we're
gonna make sure that we know
who the Habsburgs are.
We have talked about a couple
of kinds of empires so far.
We've talked about empires that break out
into the Age of Discovery
and empires that don't.
So when we think about the success
of the Russian Empire in the 18th century,
one of the broad factors behind that
was that Russia managed
to reach the Pacific
and also that Russia, by way
of English traders first,
manages to trade West as
well into the Atlantic.
Russia breaks out into the
world, not just on land,
but also by making
contact with the oceans.
A couple of other empires or large states
that don't do that are the
Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth,
which comes to an end in the 18th century,
and the Ottoman Empire,
which is weakening.
The Ottoman Empire can't break
out of the Mediterranean.
The Habsburgs are a very
interesting kind of middle case
because the Habsburgs do break
out into the wider world.
Indeed, they break out into the
wider world more effectively
and more extravagantly
and more spectacularly
than any other family.
In the early 16th century,
they are governing Spain.
By the late 18th century,
sorry, 16th century,
they're also governing Portugal.
They're governing the Netherlands
for much of the 1500s and 1600s.
Why does that matter?
Because the Spanish, the Portuguese,
and the Dutch are the major
exploring powers at the time.
If you cast a glance at the bottom part
of the map that I handed out,
which is entitled Habsburg
Earth, that gives you an idea.
We think of these things
as Spanish history,
the Spanish Empire, Portuguese history,
the Portuguese Empire.
We think of the Dutch traders,
but the Habsburgs actually
ruled these countries
in the 1500s and in the 1600s.
So the Habsburgs ruled domains
which break out into the
world more powerfully,
more spectacularly than
any other single family,
but then it's all broken in 1700,
that the Spanish branch
of the Habsburgs dies out,
and the Habsburgs at that
point are basically reduced
to being a European power.
That year, 1700, one year after 1699,
which, as you all know,
is the time of the Treaty of Karlowitz,
which marks when the Habsburgs break out
into Southeastern Europe.
So 1699, 1700, you can remember
as a kind of turning point
when the Habsburgs are
ceasing to be a world power,
but at exactly the same moment
becoming a Southeastern,
East Central, or East European power.
The final thing I wanna
say about the Habsburgs
before I get into the chronology
is that I would ask you
if you have a vision of
the Habsburgs in mind,
maybe you don't, maybe
this is all completely new,
but if you have a vision
of the Habsburgs in mind,
and you come from a francophone
or an anglophone background,
the vision that you have
in your mind is probably
very much people who were
mad, bad, and unfit to rule,
that you probably have in mind the idea
that this was some kind
of antique, cantankerous,
doomed monarchy which was anachronistic
because it had lots of nations
inside of it at the same time
and fell apart during the First World War.
That's the stereotype,
and that stereotype comes
from American and British
and French propaganda
during the First World War.
So if you come from,
if you happen to come
from those traditions,
a French or a British or
American tradition in education,
probably insofar as the
Habsburgs figure at all,
it's as a prison of
nations, yada, yada, yada.
I mean, I'm gonna puncture
that just for a moment,
just one moment.
When the Habsburgs were
fighting the Americans
at the end of the First World War,
when Wilson gave his famous speech
in which he was announcing
the principle of
self-determination, there were,
okay, I'm gonna put this as a question
'cause you guys look awake.
There were how many African Americans
in the American Congress
listening to that speech?
Come on, you can do it.
It's the safest possible guess.
Zero is correct, right?
Zero is correct,
whereas in the Habsburg
Parliament at the same time,
all the nationalities
were represented, right?
All the nationalities were represented.
So in many ways, the Habsburg
monarchy was actually
a more liberal country than
the United States of America
at the time when they were waging war.
That's just one little detail.
And when you think about
the Habsburgs today,
and you think about that stereotype,
you could also think
about it in these terms.
Were the Habsburgs behind the times or,
insofar as these ways of thinking
about things are acceptable,
maybe they were ahead of their time?
Because by the time you
get to the 19th century,
the late 19th century, early 20th century,
the Habsburgs were a multinational,
pluralistic liberal zone
with very messy politics,
but a growing economy
and not entirely unlike the
European Union of today, right?
So is that model of being multinational
and having cranky politics
based on compromise
among nationalities, is
that a thing of the past,
or is that maybe a thing of
the present or the future?
Okay, so, so much for the repair
of the image of the Habsburgs.
Now we're gonna zoom back into
the history of the Habsburgs,
and you can make your own judgements.
So the Habsburgs go all the way back.
They really are an old family.
They're not as old as they say they are.
They don't actually go back
to Remus and Romulus and the wolf,
but they do go back to the year 1020.
They built a castle
called the Habichtsburg,
which is the first sign
of their existence,
and that's the year 1020.
So basically their
existence is contemporaneous
with the foundation of
Kyivan Rus' as we know it,
which is 988.
The Habsburgs have been
around for a long time.
Most of this history isn't gonna seem
to have much to do with Ukraine,
but we need to know who they
are before they get to Ukraine.
These people make their money
by not from glamorous conquest,
and this is sort of a theme.
They make their money at the
beginning by tolls over bridges
and by taxing travelers
and things like that
in what's now Austria,
what's now Switzerland.
The one great or the greatest
Austrian Habsburg warlord
was Rudolf von Habsburg,
who was born in 1218
and is elected Holy Roman Emperor in 1273.
He's the founder of this dynasty
as a major European dynasty.
What's the Holy Roman Empire?
The Holy Roman Empire is the,
so the title of Holy
Roman Emperor is given
to the King of the Franks.
If you'll remember,
the initial geopolitics
of this class are the Franks in the West
and the Byzantines in
the South or in the East.
Charlemagne is the great
King of the Franks.
The idea that there is an
emperor is revived in the West
with the Kingdom of the Franks,
and then when that line dies out,
it's restored again in
the year 962, when Otto,
who is king of Germany, is
named Holy Roman Emperor,
crowned Holy Roman Emperor in 962.
From that point forward, until
Napoleon does away with it,
there's going to be something
called the Holy Roman Empire.
The Habsburgs are going
to claim superiority
over other families largely
by being Holy Roman Emperors
and by claiming that they always should be
Holy Roman Emperors.
But many interesting things
about the Holy Roman Empire,
that one of them is that
the emperor was elected,
admittedly, by a very
small group of electors,
of a handful of electors,
but nevertheless elected.
The way elections work though
is that they're very closely associated
with bouts of violence,
which is, of course,
something we in America
don't know anything about.
When Rudolf of Habsburg was
elected Holy Roman Emperor
in 1273, and this was
immediately contested
by probably the most impressive king
of the most impressive
kingdom of the time,
which was the wonderfully
named Otakar Premysl II, right?
The name Otakar Premysl was so good
that there had to be at
least two of them, right?
So Otakar Premysl II, who
was king of the Czechs,
he really was the probably
the most impressive ruler
of Europe at the time.
The Czechs have just done this funny thing
where they've claimed that
they've hosted, did you see this?
They've claimed that they've hosted
a referendum in Kaliningrad?
(student speaking faintly)
Yeah, that goes-
- [Student] Královec.
- Yeah, sorry, Královec.
This goes back to Otakar Premysl II
and the great Czech
kingdom of the Middle Ages.
So he immediately contest
this, and there's a huge war
in which Rudolf of Habsburg actually wins
and Otakar Premysl II is killed,
which is one of these
turning points, right?
I mean, this class is not about this,
but by rights, you could say,
the Czechs probably should have been
the dominant power in Eastern Europe,
and they just had some bad
luck at a couple of moments,
and this was one of them.
After Rudolf dies in 1291,
his son is not elected,
so his son then contests the election.
That seems like a strangely
euphemistic way of putting it.
It makes it seem like I'm
holding up a ballot or something
and say, "You didn't count this one,"
but that's not what you mean
by contest the election.
I mean that he killed
the man who was elected
on the battlefield with his own hands,
spearing him through the face,
and finishing him off with
a much feared ballock knife,
which is exactly what it sounds like,
after which he was elected, right?
After which he was elected.
So you can see the history of elections.
In the history of elections,
there's a lot of disentanglement to do
between the peaceful procedure
and the violence that attends elections,
and it's a lot of hard work.
The run of the Habsburgs
ends in a meaningful way
in 1346 when another great Czech king,
the greatest Czech king, Charles,
the one after whom the
university and the bridge,
if you've ever been there, is named.
King Charles is elected
Holy Roman Emperor in 1346.
This is very important
for the history the Czechs
and history of Central
Europe, but for our purposes,
we just wanna note that the Luxembourgs,
that's Charles' family, yes,
the same as the country,
the Luxembourgs now become Holy
Roman Emperors for a while,
and this is a big problem
for the Habsburgs,
not least because the Luxembourgs do
an extremely good job of it.
Charles promulgates something
called the Golden Bull
in 1346, which is a statute
of imperial governance,
which straightened things out,
which includes electoral procedures.
I want say that it says no ballock knife,
but it doesn't actually say that,
that would be too good to be true,
but it includes electoral
procedures so the transitions
could be a little bit
easier in the future.
The Habsburgs respond to
this in a way which is poetic
and characteristic, in
which I want you to mark
because it is a feature of this family,
as you'll know if you've
read "The Red Prince."
They respond to this
with a beautiful kind of,
a beautiful nostalgic attack.
They invent something called
the Privilegium Maius.
They just make it up.
They just make it up, which
is not an unknown theme
in East European history, by the way,
people just making up documents.
There's a lot of this later on,
which is good fun for historians.
So they just make up something called
the Privilegium Maius in 1359,
and the idea is that the
Habsburgs are the oldest family,
and the Habsburgs have the
right to rule Rome, et cetera,
because they have land grants from Nero
and land grants from Julius Caesar.
Okay, that is not true at all.
It's just completely made up,
but it's a nice story, right?
It's a nice story, and
if you have a nice story
and you have power, then
sometimes you can make
your nice story seem like it's true.
So the Luxembourgs are gonna be ruling
these Holy Roman Emperors until 1437,
at which point a crisis
and a marriage are going
to flip the Holy Roman
Empire back to the Habsburgs.
The crisis, which we've run across before,
is the Black Plague, which
begins in 1347 in Europe,
wipes out maybe 1/3 of the population.
This crisis, the pestilence,
this crisis of disease,
is associated with a spiritual crisis.
This is the time,
if you ever had like a
survey European class,
you'll remember there was one pope,
then there were two popes,
and there were three popes,
and the popes were in various places,
and they were hostage to kings and so on.
This is that period.
In the 14th century, multiple popes.
As the Black Death had died down,
a council was called in
Constance for 1414 to 1415,
and the purpose of the
Council in Constance was
to make order in the Christian
Church to make order in what?
In the Catholic Church.
And one of the ways that
order was to be made
were that these annoying heretics
from Bohemia were going to be brought in,
and the most annoying of
these heretics from Bohemia
was a fellow called Jan Hus.
So Jan Hus, J-A-N H-U-S,
I think he's on the sheet,
he was a sort of, I mean,
this is anachronistic way of putting it,
but he was a kind of pre-Protestant.
He had many ideas which would be familiar
from radical Protestantism,
like that you can preach in
the language of the people,
you can preach in the vernacular,
you should preach facing the people.
He also had the idea that,
this is a really radical idea,
the church is not an institution.
As such, the church comes
from the people, right?
Therefore, all the property of the church
is kind of up in question.
The church shouldn't be wealthy.
The wealth of the church should
be returned to the people.
These kinds of ideas,
that's just a sample,
but you can see how that would
be understood as a threat
to the established church as it was.
So on the 6th of July, 1415,
Jan Hus was burned at the stake
at the Council of Constance
after a trial, which he
found unsatisfactory.
And it's for this reason if you go,
again, if you go to Prague,
which I urge you to do,
there's a fine statue of
Jan Hus with the slogan,
(speaking in foreign language)
the truth with triumph.
The truth will be victorious.
So this is relevant for us
because this precipitates
the situation in which
the Habsburgs come back.
The Czech nobility in much
of the Czech bourgeoisie,
and many Czechs in general,
including peasants,
identify with Hus'
version of Christianity.
By the way, what was Hus' job?
He was basically the dean of a university.
Interesting, right?
So Hus, oh, and when he lectured,
just fun detail, he lectured
in Czech a lot of the time,
but his notes were in Latin.
Yeah, interesting, right?
Okay, so anyway, so Hus is killed,
but many Czechs believe in
his version of Christianity,
and they rebel against
their own Luxembourg king,
who by this time is called Sigismund,
Sigismund Luxembourg from Luxembourg.
And he picks up the challenge.
He says the heretics will be washed away.
And so there's a kind of civil war
in the Bohemian lands
against the Luxembourgs,
which was led by this fantastic guy
who I wish I had more time for, Jan Zizka,
who was a one-eyed military genius,
who invented a whole
bunch of military tactics
which were later used by other people,
like, well, stealing all the gold
from the churches is not
original, but he did that.
He did things like take, he
would take wagons full of hay
and make circles of them, right?
So as kind of mobile fortresses,
and then shoot out from the inside.
Clever things which
people hadn't seen before.
He took good advantage of firearms.
So this war goes on for a long time,
and now you see the opening.
This is the opening for the Habsburgs
because the Habsburgs, good Catholics,
volunteer to come in on the
side of the Luxembourgs,
and as the Habsburgs tend
to do, they manage to get,
they manage to connect it with marriage.
They always managed to,
this is their secret.
There's a Hungarian king
I'm gonna mention later
called Matthias Corvinus
who wrote, of course in Latin,
"Let others fight wars.
Thou, happy Austria, marry."
That slogan, which is sort
of beautiful and concise,
gives you a sense of how they got on
for those 600 years of power.
So the Habsburgs come in on the side
of the Luxembourgs in this war.
They don't actually help
very much on the battlefield,
but the leader of the Habsburg family,
the Habsburg family at the
time, who is Albert IV,
gets himself the daughter
of the Luxembourg ruler,
whose name is Elizabeth, gets
her promised as his bride.
And they marry in 1422, which
means that Albert von Habsburg
is gonna become the
successor, which he does.
He becomes Holy Roman Emperor in 1437,
and then the Habsburgs are
going to be Holy Roman Emperors
for the next three
centuries after that, right?
So Black Death, religious
confusion, religious rebellion.
The Habsburgs sneak in at the last moment,
marry the right person,
and suddenly they're
Holy Roman Emperors again
for the next three centuries.
And as Holy Roman
Emperors, what do they do?
They promulgate this Privilegium Maius.
They just issue it.
They say, "This is true.
This is official. This is law.
We have a special right to rule."
Okay, so I mentioned Corvinus.
He's the one, he mounts the
next challenge to the Habsburgs.
He's the greatest of the Hungarian
kings, Matthias Corvinus.
He actually drives the Habsburgs
from their own Austrian lands for a while
and does the sort of classic thing
of taking up residence in Vienna.
So he lives in Vienna from 1484,
but he dies in 1490,
and he's succeeded by Wladyslaw Jagiello,
who is, I hope, on your sheets,
because he features four of
this fantastic Polish letter,
which Wladyslaw
Jagiello, who is, of course,
from that Lithuanian family
which is now ruling Poland.
He becomes king of Hungary.
Now, so interestingly, Corvinus says,
"Thou, happy Austria, marry,"
but it's the happiest
marriages actually come
after Corvinus dies.
There are two unbelievably
fortunate marriages now
for the Habsburgs which
consolidate their place
in Europe and in the world.
The first has to do
with Wladyslaw Jagiello.
Wladyslaw Jagiello
enters into a marriage pact
with the head of the Habsburg family,
who at that time is Maximilian I.
Then, unhappily for him but
happily for the Habsburgs,
he dies fighting the Ottomans in 1526
at the Battle of Mohacs in
a stream under his horse.
That death triggers a marriage pact,
which means that the Habsburgs
then get to claim Hungary
as well as the Czech lands, which they do.
They claim those lands.
The Ottomans actually rule most of Hungary
for the next 150 years until 1699,
but the Habsburgs then claim those lands,
and they will eventually
effectively rule them.
Then there's an even more
extraordinary marriage pact,
which is that Maximilian I's son
marries a daughter of
Ferdinand and Isabella,
the Ferdinand and Isabella,
the ones who united Spain.
That Ferdinand and Isabella.
She's sixth in line to
the throne of Spain,
so there's no way this is gonna happen.
I'm sure many of you are married to people
who are sixth in line to some
throne or another, right?
That's just casual, right?
You probably didn't even mention that
in your Yale interviews.
You're like, "Ah, no,
I'm gonna talk about,
I'm gonna talk about
intramural rugby instead.
Don't wanna brag."
So note to video, they all laughed, right?
(class chuckling)
You can't tell when
they laugh at my jokes.
They all laughed, including the ones
who are married to someone
who's sixth in line.
So but what happens?
All of the men who are ahead of her die.
They all die.
All five of them die,
conveniently just in time
for Maximilian's son to
become king of Spain,
thereby bringing the Spanish
Empire and, shortly thereafter,
the Portuguese Empire and the Netherlands
and all the lands controlled
by the Netherlands
under the Habsburgs.
So two unbelievably lucky marriages.
Okay, so that's who the Habsburgs are
until we get to about the year 1700.
The year 1700, 1699, 1700,
is when they're established
as a European power, but not an American,
not a world power anymore
'cause the Spanish
Habsburgs die out in 1700.
1699, Treaty of Karlowitz,
they control the Balkans
as well as the Czech lands,
as well as as Hungary.
They take on a distinct European shape,
which they're more or
less gonna have until 1918
with some additions of lands from Poland,
which we're gonna talk about.
After 1700 and the extinction
of the Spanish line,
the male line of the Austrian Habsburgs
is also extinguished.
In 1740, there are no more men.
There's no male Habsburg
to take the throne.
What do they do?
And again, this is another
one of these moments
where a particular person comes to power,
and if it had been somebody else
with maybe a little bit less
intelligence and determination,
things would've gone differently.
What the Habsburgs did was they came up
with the aptly named pragmatic sanction,
which meant that if there
are no male Habsburgs,
how about a female Habsburg?
Very pragmatic, right?
Pragmatic, I mean, pragmatic
from their point of view
because what's always
happening to these families
is that the male line dies
out and then there's a war,
and then somebody else's
male line takes over.
Why not a woman?
So Maria Theresia takes over as empress
of the Habsburg lands in 1740.
She's immediately challenged in a way
which we would now refer
to as highly gendered
by Frederick of Prussia, who says that,
he says, this is how it's gendered.
He says, "Sure, you have the
right to rule, that's all fine,
but I think I need to decide for you
which territories you
get to rule." (chuckling)
So the Prussians make
war on the Habsburgs.
Who were the Prussians?
If you can just remember
from a couple lectures ago,
Prussia on the Baltic Sea,
successor state of Teutonic Knights,
little tiny thing which the
Poles allowed to survive,
but then when the Poles get into trouble,
the Prussians become a
kingdom, they start to expand,
and their ruling family,
the Hohenzollerns,
are just gonna keep
expanding, keep expanding,
keep expanding, until in 1871
they're gonna unify Germany.
So we're kind of in the middle
of that story with Frederick.
So Frederick makes war on the
Habsburg monarchy in 1740.
The Habsburg monarchy
defends itself very well.
They lose one territory,
which Maria Theresia will
always want back and never get,
which is called Silesia.
But meanwhile, and
there's a lot of meanwhile
for Maria Theresia when it
comes to bearing children.
Meanwhile, she does bear a son in 1741,
beginning a new house, Habsburg-Lorraine,
which is gonna rule until 1918.
As the English wits then put it,
the enemy has lost its chance
for Austria now wears pants.
So when I tell you all the things
that Maria Theresia has done,
I want you to bear in mind
that in the next 19 years,
she's going to have 15
more children, right?
So 16 children in 19 years,
plus the things we're talking about,
and, yes, she had childcare.
Okay, so 1756 to 1763
is the next major conflict
between Prussia and the Habsburgs.
On the world scale, this
is the Seven Years' War.
This is the British
and the French fighting
in North America.
This is the British gaining
dominance over India.
The Seven Years' War,
like, it's a world war.
It's a legitimately global conflict,
but for our purposes, it's one more time
when the Habsburgs fight
the Prussians to withdraw
under Maria Theresia
and continue to survive.
Then politics turns in 1772
with the First Partition of Poland.
Now the slightly unfair thing
about the partition of Poland,
as I'm sure all of you
Polonophile will have noticed,
is that it's not that long before,
it's 1683 when the Polish
armies have come to Vienna
and raised the Ottoman
siege and protected Vienna,
and then help the Austrians
to begin this series of victories,
which will end in 1699 with Karlowitz.
Less than 100 years later,
89 years later, 1772,
the Habsburgs are going to take part,
along with the Prussians
and along with the Russian
Empire under Catherine,
they're gonna take part
in the First Partition,
the First Partition of Poland.
And it is in this partition
that the Austrians take this territory
which they call Galicia,
which is a beautiful example
of imperial naming and renaming.
If you are Ukrainian,
you'll know that there's
a town called Halych
and that there's a
region called Halychyna.
And from Halych, Halychyna,
there's a Latin name, from
which you can make in German,
Galytsiya for which we
call Galicia, right?
And so they name the territories
that they claim in 1772.
They named them Galicia and Lodomeria.
Lodomeria is even more wonderful.
So there's a historical,
they're historical crown lands.
As you know in this class, of Galicia,
we call them Galicia and Volhynia.
Volhynia has a town in
it called Volodymyr.
From that town Volodymyr, you
get the Latin name Lodomeria,
which, let's admit, it
sounds kind of cool.
And so the Habsburgs claim
that they're ruling Galicia and Lodomeria.
Galicia and Lodomeria.
In fact, they don't
actually rule Lodomeria,
which is another part about imperial.
Always err on the side of
claiming more than you actually...
The Habsburgs also were
kings of Jerusalem.
You might not have known that,
but they were kings of Jerusalem, right?
There's always a long, no, I
mean, this is how you rule.
There's always a long list of things,
and somewhere in that middle of the list,
like it kind of blurs from
things that you might control
to things that your uncle controlled,
to things that you never
really controlled, right?
But there's always a long
list of stuff that you ruled.
Okay, so, okay, where are we?
So Maria Theresia, the partitions.
So it's the First Partition of Poland
that brings Galicia into
the Habsburg monarchy, 1772.
The last thing on her mind
were all the Ukrainian speakers there,
or, for that matter, all of
the Yiddish speakers there.
This is not this class, but just FYI,
adding Galicia to the
Habsburg monarchy brings
in all the families who then
a couple of generations later
are going to create German
modernity in Vienna, right?
So for example, the Freud family, right?
All these families are
going to start in Galicia,
take a station stop in
Moravia, end up in Vienna,
and then they're going to create.
They're gonna create Art Nouveau.
They're gonna create German modernism,
zivilisation basically, circa 1900.
So this partition also
had that meaning, right?
If the Austrians don't
take this territory,
and, let's say, the Russians do,
then there are not gonna be,
there are not gonna be
German-speaking Jews in Vienna
around the year 1900
to make Vienna the city
that you're all gonna visit
this summer, basically.
Right? Okay.
So there are three partitions
of Poland: 1772, 1793, 1795,
and by the time the dust settles,
Russia has taken most of it.
Very roughly speaking,
the Left Bank, that is the western part,
is added to what Russia already
gained a century before,
which is the Right Bank
or the eastern part.
Almost all of Ukraine is now
under the Russian Empire.
The exception, the very,
very important exception,
is Galicia, which is
now under the Habsburgs
in this new zone.
And this Galicia in the
Third Partition is extended
to include what is now
basically south-central Poland.
So Krakow.
Krakow, after a little while,
is going to be inside this Galicia.
So this Galicia has Polish
speakers, Yiddish speakers,
Ukrainian speakers, and it's
now a district in Austria.
So the very last thing
we have to do is talk
about what is special in
Austria in the 19th century.
Skim over the first part.
The first part is the post-Napoleonic part
when all the European
dynasties are embarrassed,
and then they tend to
crack down afterwards,
the Age of Metternich,
the age when Austria
invents the police state,
the age of systematic censorship,
the 1820s and the 1830s.
This comes to an end with
the Revolution of 1848,
which is a broad European conflagration
from Belgium through
France, through Austria.
It's the time when Karl Marx wrote
this little thing called
"The Communist Manifesto."
That was also 1848.
At the end of 1848 in Austria,
the most interesting
thing that has happened
is that a teenager, he's
18 at the time, I believe,
Franz Joseph comes to power,
and Franz Joseph is going
to be the ruler of
Austria from 1848 to 1916.
He's going to be setting
the political tone
during all that time.
From our point of view, an
interesting thing that happens
in the Revolutions of 1848
has to do with the Poles
and the Ukrainians, and it
reveals an Austrian tactic,
which is very important
to nation building.
So it's not the most heroic
part of nation building,
but it's a very important
part of nation building.
In 1848, the Austrians have some reason
to be concerned about the Poles.
Less the Ukrainians, more the Poles.
The Poles have had their
own state until 1795.
The Poles have a nobility.
They have some wealth.
Some of the Poles have gotten
into the Austrian bureaucracy.
And so what do they do in 1848 in Galicia?
They encourage the Ukrainians, right?
They encourage the Ukrainians.
They encourage the establishment
of something called
Ukrainian National Council,
which then makes Ukrainian
political demands.
So rather than directly suppressing
or intimidating the Poles, they say,
"Oh, look what we can do over here.
Oh, there's some Ukrainians
who also live there.
I bet they would like some things."
And so the Ukrainians
issue political demands
like dividing Austria in
half, which is gonna be,
I mean, not Austria, Galicia in half
into a western, eastern part,
which will be a Ukrainian
idea all the way through,
all the way through 1918.
And so this is, I mean,
this is going to be,
this kind of idea of compromise
is gonna be crucial
all the way to the end,
and I just wanna set it
up for you structurally.
The Ukrainians were not exactly
a national minority in Austria.
A national minority would be
more like in interwar Poland,
which we're gonna talk about soon enough,
where it really is a nation state
for the Poles and the Ukrainians.
Five million, six million
Ukrainian speakers are a minority.
But in the Habsburg
monarchy, it's more like
the Ukrainians are one
group of people in Galicia
and where they're contesting
things with the Poles.
And when they contest things,
they have somewhere to go besides violence
or besides direct
confrontation, which is Vienna.
They can go to Vienna.
The Habsburgs are at the top,
and the Habsburgs are
always gonna be capable
down to the end of saying,
"Okay, as a matter of fact,
let's make another compromise.
Let's redo this. Let's redo that.
Let's redo this. Let's redo that,"
which isn't the most exciting
form of politics, I admit,
again, cross reference to European Union,
but it might be a form of
politics, of national politics,
which is more durable than people thought
in the 19th century or the 20th century.
So this form of politics
comes alive after 1867.
So the other part of the
famous saying of Corvinus,
"Let others fight wars.
Thou, happy Austria, marry,"
the slightly unkind part would
be the suggestion that maybe
that the Austrians are
going to lose a lot of wars,
which is also true, right?
They didn't exactly cover
themselves with glory
in the wars of the 19th
and the early 20th century.
They got embarrassed in 1859,
and which began the process
of Italian unification.
They really got embarrassed
in 1866 with the Germans,
which is the beginning of the
story of German unification.
After they lost a war to Germany,
the Habsburgs had to make a compromise
from position of weakness
with the most important
nationality within their borders,
which is the Hungarians.
And this is the famous Ausgleich of 1867.
That's one of these words,
like later on Anschluss.
They're five German
words you have to know,
and two of them are
Ausgleich and Anschluss.
I don't have time for the
jokes about the other three.
We're running out of time.
Hopefully it's some other
lecture, but, anyway,
ausgleich just means compromise,
just means compromise,
but in this context, it
means the Compromise of 1867
in which the Hungarian nobility
was basically given the
right to become a state
within a state of the Habsburg monarchy
and to do as they please with the Slovaks,
the Slovaks, the Croats, the Romanians.
The remainder of Austria,
which is in a funny kind of
sea shape around Hungary,
from Galicia through Moravia,
Bohemia, Austria itself,
down the Adriatic Coast,
what's now Slovenia,
what's now Croatia, that
Austria was governed after 1867
by a kind of constitutional law
which promised things
like freedom of speech,
which promised equal
rights for individuals
and equal rights for nations.
Never quite defined what a nation was,
but equal rights for individuals,
equal rights for nations.
It's in this particular
version of Austria,
not the Hungarian part,
the non-Hungarian part,
that the story of Ukrainian
nationality plays out.
And by now you will have
noticed the timing, right?
The timing, the timing, the timing.
After 1867, many things are possible.
After 1867, freedom of
speech, individual freedom.
After 1867, Austria is gonna move
until by 1907, there's gonna
be full manhood suffrage,
which is pretty advanced for
the standards of the time.
The United States didn't
have it, for example.
And that means that along
with full manhood suffrage,
the right of all males to
vote, comes political parties,
and with political parties
come political campaigns
and political demands, and
with political campaigns
and political demands
come newspapers, right?
Because there's freedom of speech.
And that includes, among
many, many other things,
Ukrainian newspapers,
Ukrainian political parties,
Ukrainian political demands,
which even if they're not fulfilled,
they're out there and they're aired.
And again, the timing,
this is from 1867 to 1914.
The timing is the same
moment when Ukrainian culture
and any kind of politics
becomes impossible
in the Russian Empire.
That's so important to everything
because after 1867,
the leading thinkers and
activists from the Russian Empire,
when they are banned after
1863 and again in 1876,
when they're banned by the Valuev Circular
and the Ems Decree from
using Ukrainian language,
where do they go?
They go to Galicia.
They go to the Habsburg monarchy, right?
And the timing is that the
timing is so important here.
Absolutely crucial.
The Habsburg monarchy is becoming a place
where you can do Ukrainian politics
at exactly the moment the Russian
Empire is becoming a place
where you can't do Ukrainian politics
or, for that matter, Ukrainian culture.
And because the center of
Ukrainian intellectual, political,
and cultural life was
actually the Russian Empire,
this means that all these
people are coming into Galicia
who can do things like occupied share
in East European history, right?
There's a fellow called
Mykhailo Hrushevs'kyi,
the most important historian of Ukraine,
who basically applies the methods
of what we would call social history
and writes a continuous history
of Ukraine from the Middle Ages.
Hrushevs'kyi leaves the Russian
Empire, comes to Galicia,
and, lo and behold, he
has a chair in Lviv.
He has a chair,
and he's able to teach
this version of history,
which that's actually
incredibly significant, right?
The difference between nobody and one,
and nobody having to
share in Ukrainian history
and the most important
Ukrainian chair having to share
in Ukrainian history and lecturing
and publishing his books,
very, very important.
But that's just pars pro toto.
That's just one example
of many other things.
Very important thinkers,
like Panteleimon Kulish, like Drahomanov,
they all come from the East
and they go to the West,
and they bring radical political ideas.
They bring the idea, for
example, a fundamental idea,
which I'll just mention
and then we'll move on,
that politics belongs
to the people as such.
So in the Russian Empire,
the serfs were freed in 1861,
which raises the basic question of, okay,
if they're free of
bondage, who now owns them?
Whom do they belong?
Are they gonna be loyal to the czar?
Are they gonna be loyal to something else?
And the main radical political reaction,
the end of serfdom, was something called,
in the Russian Empire was called populism
or going to the people.
The Ukrainian populists were
the ones who went to the people
and found out they were
Ukrainian, essentially,
which coincides in time with the emergence
of a new discipline of science
which we call anthropology,
but at the time was called ethnography,
which we think of as the
method of anthropology.
At the time, they said
ethnography for the science.
Going to the people,
recording their songs,
recording their stories,
recording their history,
recording everything you can,
taking the people seriously
as an object of science coincides
with taking the people seriously
as an object of politics.
And it leads to the notion
that in addition to history
and politics and power
mattering for a nation,
also the people and its culture
and its durability matter.
So if there are songs,
if there's a culture,
if there's a language, then
that means there's a nation.
This is the ethnographic idea of a nation,
a very powerful idea, and that
ethnographic idea of a nation
is obviously very useful in Galicia,
not against the Russians,
Russians don't matter in Galicia,
but against the Poles because in Galicia,
I mean, this is so important,
it's not that the Ukrainians
are a national minority
struggling against the center.
No, no, no, no.
The Ukrainians are
struggling against the Poles
and the Polish gentry.
After 1867, the Poles
as a historical nation,
as people said back
then, as a gentry nation,
they are also the
beneficiaries of a compromise.
They get control over
schools, very important.
They get a local parliament.
They get some control
over local administration.
And what does that give
for the Ukrainians?
It gives the Ukrainians
something to struggle for, right?
And in some of that,
they're gonna claw back
and get control of, especially
at the level of schooling.
They're gonna claw back and
try to get control of that.
In the free politics, it was possible,
the Habsburg monarchy.
But what are the intellectual
or ideological weapons they're gonna use?
The Polish argument is that we're a nation
because we always were.
It's not that the Polish
speaking peasants are the nation.
They didn't think that, right?
The nation are the gentry.
The nation are the people
who used to be able to vote
in the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth,
the gentry, the historical nobility.
That's the nation, the historical
nation, as people said.
But the Ukrainians now
have a different kind
of argument to make.
Their argument can be, well,
maybe we don't have the gentry.
Maybe we weren't the political
class a hundred years ago
in the Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth,
but at least in certain
parts of the territories,
we have the people, we have the majority,
we have the culture,
and that is the nation.
And that's a very
powerful argument, right?
That's a very powerful...
That version of the nation, by the way,
is broadly victorious.
I mean, people can disagree
about this and that,
but you wouldn't generally say like,
there are very few countries
now where you can say,
"I belong to the nation
because I belong to nobility."
In general, if I say nation now,
you're not gonna think of some elite.
You're gonna tend to think of everybody
or at least some large group, right?
So Ukrainians, with the help of the,
Ukrainians and Galicia with the help
of the Ukrainians coming
for the Russian Empire
can make this argument.
They can say, "We're the majority."
And this argument also has,
it also has political ramifications.
It means if you mobilize
enough people to vote,
you can send your representatives
to parliament, as they do.
You can have debates in parliament
You can make your camp.
They never win this argument,
but they make it to the end,
but we should divide
Galicia into East and West,
and have our own Eastern Galicia.
And so with the help of these
people, with the help of,
with the help of these arguments,
but above all with the help
of the very specific
Habsburg political system,
the period between 1867
and 1914 becomes the period
when Ukrainian politics explodes.
Ukrainian politics becomes mass politics.
There are suddenly Ukrainian nationalists
and Ukrainian socialists
and Ukrainian liberals,
and Ukrainian every possible thing,
and Ukrainian newspapers,
Ukrainian civil life.
Civic life, in other words.
That in turn is going to
be incredibly important
when we get to the moment
when the empires begin to break up,
which is the First World War,
which is where we're gonna
start again next time.
So thank you very much.
(bright tones resonating)